Speaker 1: All right, let's get into this
week's mailbag info at David Pakman dot com
is the place to email if you have something
to say.
Sometimes we'll take a YouTube comment or
a tweet reply or a Facebook message or whatever.
Starting today, in fact, indeed, with a Facebook
message from Jionni who said, you look like
a SoI jack in real life effing loser.
Now, this was a new one.
I recently asked on my Twitter, What does
it mean to be compelled?
Not a term I had heard before last week, and
it was unclear what it meant.
I also didn't know what a soy jack is, so
I look this one up.
This one apparently is a meme which is often
used in online discourse where you post a
soy jack, which I guess is an image.
And the idea is when you post it, you're saying
the person you're arguing online with is a
beta soy boy.
So that's that.
And apparently I am a soy jack in real life,
maybe not on the Internet, but in real life
I am a soy jack.
So very, very important messaging there.
Brandon wrote in about a potential Biden pardon
of Trump.
And Brandon says David, longtime listener,
first time question, wondering if you could
unpack the hypothetical scenario of Biden
pardoning Trump in an effort to bring the
country together to avoid the inevitable political
and cultural turmoil of such a process?
Thank you for your levelheaded perspective.
You know, I don't think it's completely out
of the realm of possibility that if the next
few months or the next year for Trump go in
a particular way, and I would call it going
south, for lack of a better term.
I actually don't think it's completely impossible
that Biden would consider such a pardon again
to unite the country sort of in the way that
it happened with Nixon.
But my hope is that he wouldn't do that, because
at some point we have to be if no one is above
the law, it means not only that anybody can
be charged, but it has to mean that people
actually have to have consequences for the
things that they do if they are found guilty
of doing those things.
So I do think Brandon's instinct is right
that Biden does seem like the type of guy
who would go above partizanship and in certain
scenarios might say, I'm going to pardon Donald
Trump.
We're thinking many steps ahead, but I hope
that it doesn't happen because I do think
that we really need to put our money where
our mouths are when it comes to individuals
not being above the law.
And that means when there's a consequence,
you don't get out of it because you used to
be the president.
Greg wrote in about this deep state assassination
plot theory.
We've heard from right wingers like Steve
Bannon and Rudy Giuliani and others over the
last few weeks that the Mar a Lago raid might
be the first step by the Deep State to eventually
assassinate Donald Trump.
And it sounds crazy.
Greg says, Here's my theory regarding the
deep state assassination attempt.
You're always saying that when the right is
accusing, they're usually the ones guilty.
I believe they're floating it out there for
one of their own to assassinate Trump so that
they can make a martyr out of him in hopes
to push their agenda further and also make
the Democrats look terrible.
What are your thoughts?
Thanks.
Love the show.
Right.
That's an interesting idea.
And in fact, there could be two layers in.
Let's just think about motive just because
it's fun, even if we don't think this is really
what's going on.
If you are a Republican and you're worried
that Trump is really terrible for your movement.
You could say, hey, you know what's perfect,
let's get Trump killed, because then one,
we get him out of the way.
And two, we can run on the left.
Killed him.
And it'll just be great for us.
We can have a non-Trump candidate energized
by this alleged assassination of Trump, by
the deep state or by the left or whatever.
Certainly a beautiful, beautiful idea.
I don't think that that is what they are planning
in this particular case.
But if you disagree, certainly let me know
because it's an interesting one.
Keith also wrote to me about the Trump assassination
and Trump and Keith says, David, what group
has brought up assassination?
The far right.
Trump is cooked.
He's going to be a bad package as investigations
continue.
It is not the Democrats or some nutty deep
state.
It will be the Republicans getting traction
and political support as Republicans take
him out.
The Republican leadership are done with him
and want to take control of their party again.
Make Trump a martyr, cause a total political
uproar.
Bannon will take him out.
Well, listen, if the right wants to kill Trump,
I don't think it's going to be Bannon.
But Keith, with a similar idea there for sure.
And again, I get the motive.
Truly, the motive actually does make a lot
of sense, but I don't actually think that
that's what's going on.
Austin has sort of gotten to the end of his
rope.
Austin wrote in and says, If Herschel Walker
wins, I'm out.
David Sir, this is of Roy.
Well, okay.
The email says it's Austin, but then says
it's Roy.
This is Roy from South Jersey.
As we know, Herschel Walker is a disgrace,
a joke and cannot speak.
But this crossed the line.
His ex-wife aired a commercial where she described
him choking, beating and pointing a gun at
her on multiple occasions.
Walker's response went, quote, When they attacking
me, that means they're scared of me.
They know I'm going to be the one to win that
seat because they got to come out and try
to attack me.
Continue to bring up things that is really
helping me.
I wanted them.
I'm glad they brought up the attack with my
ex-wife.
This is done a long time ago.
It was done to help people because that commercial
there only tells people, I'm going to continue
to be a warrior.
I'm going to continue to fight for mental
health.
Him beating his wife was done to help other
people.
If he wins, I'm moving.
I don't know where, but I cannot live in a
country where one of 100 senators is this
mentally challenged and or evil.
I don't know that I would use all the exact
same words that Austin slash Roy is using
here.
But there is a certain despondency that I
completely identify with.
If this guy can win, despite being unable
to even put together a coherent sentence over
the intelligent and well-versed and politically
knowledgeable Rafael Warnock, it would be
such a humiliation for everything we know
of our country.
And listen, I'm not threatening to move, but
it would be really, really bad.
Brian wrote in about both lines and says,
David, did you see the Beau Hines interview?
He's a Trump endorsed former college football
player that's running for Congress in North
Carolina.
He thinks when people are calling the U.S.
a banana republic, they're referring to the
clothing store.
The Republican Party is indistinguishable
from an SNL skit or an Onion article.
Bryan from Minnesota I did see that.
It's a wild clip.
I don't have it pulled up here, but you can
easily find it if you Google Beau Hinds Banana
Republic.
He talks about like when he mentions, Oh,
they're calling us a banana republic.
He talks about the manager of a banana republic
store.
Like he completely doesn't get that.
Banana republic is a pejorative for countries
whose, you know, the idea is that they've
gotten advanced enough to produce bananas.
And it's a pejorative and it's not a term
that I tend to use, quite frankly.
Keith wrote in and says, Conservatives aren't
a fraction of the population, especially when
considering that demographics show that as
of 2021, 23% of Americans age 18 to 29 are
considered conservative, compared to 45% of
Americans 65 plus.
Likewise, 34% of Americans 18 to 29 are liberal,
compared to 21% of Americans 65 plus.
Compare the conservative and liberal stats
and that would be 68% demographic majority
compared to a 55% Liberal minority, hardly
a fraction of the population of conservatives,
as you falsely stated.
It also wasn't a fraction of the population
that got Trump elected into office.
A Gallup poll as recently as 2019 showed conservatives
outnumber liberals 25 states and highly in
19 states.
Based on all of that, you have no idea what
you're talking about.
So, no, Keith, I'm sorry.
You have no idea what I'm talking about.
So there's two things here.
And all of this word salad doesn't address
it.
Number one.
When you talk to people about their views
on issues, you quickly realize that the country
is as left as it has been since polling has
existed.
You ask about should the government provide
a basic level of health care to everybody
even if they can't pay?
You look at the answers on that.
You ask people, should the government tax
the very rich in order to help the very poor
have a basic standard of living?
You ask about whether abortion should be legal
in most cases.
You ask about gay marriage.
You ask about Is climate change real?
When you talk to people about issues, you
find an electorate that is as left as it has
been in the modern political era.
Number two, it really is a minority that got
Trump elected into office.
Only about half the country votes.
And less than half of those who voted voted
for Trump.
Right.
Hillary got more votes and Biden got more
votes.
Okay.
So it is literally a minority of the country
that got Trump elected.
So the polls you're talking about are how
do people self-identify?
I know tons of people that say I'm a conservative
and then I ask them their views on issues
and they're liberal on every issue.
So it is you that is confused, Keith.
And I would encourage you to, you know, maybe
read up a little bit.
Jessica wrote in and says, David, sir, you've
already addressed several times the Conservatives
response to all criticism of Herschel Walker,
his inability to vocalize his thoughts on
any subject.
But I can't recall you emphasizing the context.
He's running for Senate, which requires intellectual
capacity.
The definition of discrimination is unjust
or prejudicial treatment, so it is not discriminatory
to expect the person making the most consequential
decisions for the entire country to make some
sense.
Yeah, that's a fair point.
Often when I and others criticize Herschel
Walker for being unable to express his political
positions on any issue, for being unable to
speak coherently, for just mumbling word salads
that don't make any sense, some of the reaction
will be, oh, you know, you're you're discriminating
against people who maybe lack education or
lack cognitive capacity or have mental illness
or have chronic traumatic encephalopathy or
whatever.
No, what I'm saying is we have 100 senators
and they should be able to think clearly and
express themselves coherently.
And so Walker doesn't meet the requirements.
And, of course, in a literal sense, the requirements
are to be a citizen and to be the right age,
but and to live in the state in which you're
running.
What we would all as a collective society,
I think, agree on is we should have smart
people who can understand issues and explain
themselves and speak.
It is not discriminatory in the sense that
he doesn't meet those fundamental basics.
And I think Jessica is completely correct.
Paul wrote in about electric cars.
And he does not like my recent defenses of
electric cars, saying cars are the most dangerous,
inefficient, expensive and environmentally
and socially harmful means of transportation
available electric cars reduce one of those
problems carbon emissions, although with some
offsetting costs in terms of mining, if you
really want to address the climate disaster,
you need to focus on a host of reforms which
will reduce or eliminate our dependency on
cars as our primary means of transportation.
Listen, I'm right there with you.
There is no greater advocate than me for better
public transit.
This means both within and between cities.
Our national rail is a complete and total
joke.
We are in many cities.
Public transit is a joke.
I would much rather a future in which vehicles
are sort of on demand and driverless so that
listen.
For most of us, our cars sit in a driveway
on the street or in a garage 90% of the time
or more of the day.
Most people most people aren't driving two
and a half hours a day, which is like 10%
of the day.
So my preference would be dramatically reduce
the number of vehicles, have an on demand
system where when you actually need a vehicle,
it shows up, gets you where you need to go
and then brings other people around.
The reforms we need are dramatic, dramatic
and yes, obviously just public transit is
great.
The reality in the United States, when there
are so many suburban and rural areas is it
seems more likely to me that on demand, autonomous
electric vehicles are going to be.
A better fit for parts of the country than
like bus high capacity busses where you just
don't have the number of people needing these
particular routes to justify it financially
in much of the country.
That is the perfect solution.
So listen, I'm with Paul.
But when it comes to electric vehicles versus
internal combustion engines, I am on the side
of electric vehicles.
Info at David Pakman dot com questions.
Comments.
Whatever.
Let me know.
Info at David Pakman dot com.
And of course, make sure that you are signed
up at join pack mint.com so that you get instant
access to the bonus show.
Speaker 3: O the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Hard to make a better case for
the bonus show than that.
Join pacman dot com.
We will see you then.
O today on the bonus show I will tell the
story of my first visit to a Starbucks in
20 years.
It happened earlier this week.
How did it happen and what happened?
I will tell you.